[Music]
hey you guys what's going on it's
monday it's monday yes monday yeah sorry
i have a little bit of a cold so my
voice sounds kind of [ __ ] up more than
usual i never caught that it came down
with it and then i started spraying that
colloidal silver and [ __ ] taking zinc
well you had a sore throat had a sore
throat
sore back of my nose was sore for a
couple days and then it went away
yeah it's not i mean mine's really not
it's not that bad it's just kind of like
annoying
anything should have drinks in that
colloidal silver nah [ __ ] doesn't do
anything it did something for me every
time how do you know it just seems like
it never really it's like if you catch
it early it's like you sidestep you know
and i think zinc also helped that's all
right eating a bunch of zinc
i'll be all right zinc and vitamin d i
don't usually get all that sick anyway
yeah danny rolling says paulie's
restaurant in this film was used in a
canadian show called beachcombers and
now it's a restaurant called molly's
reach which i definitely want to eat
they're just saying hey that's pretty
cool
uh kanavathan says never seen this one
yeah i kind of feel like this is one of
those stephen king adaptations that uh
sort of people forget about it's pretty
good
yeah it's not great uh but it's it's
pretty good it's a pretty good one i
mean obviously it came kind of like a
few years after one of the best stephen
king adaptations which was misery
and came out the year before
another one of the best stephen king
adaptations which was the shawshank
redemption
so this is another one that's kind of
like mid-tier i feel like everybody in
is famous max von sodell plays like a
devil he's good in it
yeah he's the best part about this
really he plays it well
uh i would consider it like a max von
sideout movie
yeah he's really like the main reason to
watch this but i mean it has a great
cast like ed harris is in it he has like
a big part bonnie bedelia is in it you
know she was in die hard obviously among
other things jt walsh is in it like
amanda plummer is in it like a whole
bunch of people are in it it's like
really cool basic premises the [ __ ]
devil shows up in town
gets it gets his grip on the town by
getting to know everybody of course he
just looks like a regular man
and um
throws so many crosses between the
people he gets the entire town to
[ __ ] fight each other to destroy the
town and it's pretty cool how it comes
out you can see a lot of stephen king
stuff in it i never read the book
but uh i could
watch the movie i could imagine how it
was described or written in the book
when king describes things the dude who
killed his wife and regretted it and
[ __ ] kind of like the trash can man kind
of like that he had a lot of characters
like that
i could well i kind of feel like
i read this book but it was a long time
ago i mean i've read most of stephen
king's stuff like pre-90s
so
uh so i definitely did read this one i
kind of feel like the thing about
needful things though the book is
[ __ ] long and it has like a lot of
character development and there's a lot
of characters because it kind of like
goes into all the relationships between
everybody in this town and it's actually
really good so i kind of feel like i
mean it's not really the filmmaker's
fault but you can't really
cram all that into one movie
interestingly and i haven't seen the
longer version but
the version that's on we watched it on
peacock
it's on there for free
is i think two hours
now tbs i believe
like right around a year or two after
this came out they showed it on tv and
they showed like a three hour version so
they put like an hour's worth of [ __ ]
back in there and like some of the
scenes were rearranged and whatnot so i
haven't seen the longer version and
maybe it's good because i kind of feel
like
i think that's really the only complaint
that i would make about this movie is
that it doesn't really have time to
get more into like all the characters
like all the relationships between one
another because it's trying to like put
forward
you know the the premise and so they
don't really have a lot of time to like
get down to like all the characters and
stuff because there are so many and i'm
sure they like trimmed it down somebody
says this like the dark half i'd say no
no i like the dark half but it's not
like the dark f although interestingly
did you know that the character of alan
pangborn uh the sheriff who ed harris
plays in this movie is also a character
in the dark half except in that movie
he's played by michael rooker
yeah uh but he's so because it's set in
the same town castle rock so some of the
characters enter uh overlap and actually
they don't mention this in
needful things the movie
but in the book needful things leland
gaunt who is like you know the devil guy
he actually hires ace merrell to be his
assistant and ace merrell was the bully
from
the body which was made into stand by me
so there's a lot of kind of like
character uh characters like showing up
in both things
um yeah what's those needful things a
really good movie said sebastian uh
danny rowling said this would have to be
my favorite stephen king adaptation film
and book just saying interesting because
like i said i kind of feel like this one
slips under the radar i had kind of like
forgotten about i had seen it before um
but i'd kind of like forgotten about it
until
i was on peacock because we were
watching
the 1984 fire starter and they had some
other stephen king adaptations on there
i was like oh needful things i haven't
seen that in a really long time like we
should watch that and talk about it
you guys said i liked the mist despite
the cgi i really liked the mystery as
well yeah uh and i actually really like
i know the ending is kind of uh divisive
because it's different from stephen
king's ending but i kind of like the
ending i like that it was like really
[ __ ] depressing i thought that was
pretty awesome
um it was depressing but it kind of
showed the army as winning
which you know what i mean which that's
not the way it was in the book in the
book they just travel on to the mist and
they were they were [ __ ] they never
stopped i mean in the book it was just
kind of like ambiguous yeah like it just
kind of left it hopeful but maybe it's
not gonna you know i think it would i
think they should have maybe shown what
happened to them but i don't think they
ever showed the army stop in the mist
yeah
because because it was always open that
was always open when i read that short
is that he might write a book happening
in that universe
yeah because i always liked stephen king
when he was talking about parallel
universes like the gunslinger universe
or the dark tower universe yeah and then
um the talisman universe yeah talisman
where you're in a multi we use the black
house which is that one that he wrote
with peter straub yeah the [ __ ]
i always liked when king was talking
about something that wasn't quite wasn't
taking place in this world but it's
parallel universe a lot better a lot
better because it opened and it opens up
a lot of
a lot of possibilities talking about
[ __ ] that never existed but could have
yeah i'm talking about yeah yeah i mean
he's got
in the gunslinger he's got guns in well
he had it in the same thing in the
talisman he's mentioning guns that only
existed in parallel universes you know
like ruger 45 automatics and [ __ ] but
that was in the time when ruger didn't
make those it's just kind of cool [ __ ]
you know
danny rowling says the truest form of
this tv adaptation film can only be
found on vhs which they never should
have cut out of the film in my opinion
yeah i kind of i haven't seen the longer
version like i said because we just
watched like the theatrical cut but i
have heard that there is a much longer
version than one of this which is like
three three and a half hours long
something like that
and i do kind of feel like maybe this
would benefit from being like expanded
out just because it has so many
characters and i think it would be good
if they kind of like drilled down a
little bit into
the relationships between the people
that were sort of there and sort of like
festering before leland got there
because that's kind of what leland
gone's whole thing is it's implied that
yeah he's the devil essentially
and he just goes from town to town
because this is i guess something that
the devil likes to do he just likes to
[ __ ] with people and he just goes from
town to town and
in this particular town i don't know if
he does the same thing in every town or
not you're kind of led to believe that
it's a similar kind of thing he comes to
the town he opens up like an antique
store type deal called needful things
and when you go in there
he seems to have exactly the one thing
that you've always wanted now in the
movie it just seems like he's like hey
i've got that thing that you wanted like
and he's supernatural so he can guess
what that is
in the book i think it's more clear that
he just gives you like some worthless
crap and almost it almost has like a
glamour on it so you see it as whatever
you want it to be kind of like it gives
you the push
yeah kind of like that so i don't think
they went so much into that in the movie
i think he just he just would have like
magically whatever and you know i guess
it doesn't really matter but you know
what's interesting you know who directed
this
uh phrase frazier c
heston
the son
of charlton has
directed this movie and this was
actually the only movie that he ever
directed that his dad wasn't in
i didn't even know that he directed
movies just goes to show what i know and
the guy that wrote the screenplay
which is obviously adapted from the
novel
also adapted
uh the 1978 version of invasion of the
body snatchers
he directed the adventures of buckaroo
bonsai which is a great cult movie
and he co-wrote big trouble in little
china
so there you go too but yeah so
so basically what his whole deal is is
that he gets people to
he's like here's this thing that you've
always wanted like the the main object
that you've always wanted
and
you and i'll just like take 95 cents or
whatever the [ __ ] for it or whatever
money you have for but you also have to
like play a prank for me and it's not a
big deal and no one will ever know it
was you
and then he'll tell you what what he
wants you to do so what he's basically
trying to do is turn everybody against
one another
so at the beginning he has like this
little boy and the little boy comes in
and like the thing that he wants more
than anything is like this 1956 i think
it's 1956 mickey mental like baseball
card or whatever and he's like yeah i
have that and look it's even like made
out to you and all this stuff like with
your name on it and [ __ ] and he's like
all you have to do
is
kind of like throw mud and turkey [ __ ]
like onto
disney well that's what it was it was
like muck you know uh you know onto the
neighbors like sheets or whatever
and so he does that
and she thinks that it's amanda
plummer's character neddy cobb because
those two have been like feuding so then
like the feud kind of like blows up so
that's kind of like what his mo is in
town it's just making everybody think
that everybody is like [ __ ] everybody
else over so it's like it just keeps
escalating and escalating and escalating
until you know people are [ __ ]
you know jt walsh's character is like
beating his wife to death with a hammer
and it's like people are like planting
bombs in the church and [ __ ] like that
so it just keeps going and you know and
meanwhile like max von said i was just
sitting back there with his with his
long ass yucky fingernails being like
you know what i mean so it's like but
for some reason like ed harris's
character they don't really specify and
i don't remember if they specified in
the book or not maybe somebody that's
read the book more recently can tell me
but um
why i guess they kind of like say this
in the movie but like why he doesn't
succumb
to the same thing that everyone else is
succumbing to i guess because when he
comes in the shop
and
leland asked him like what
you know what do you want more than
anything he's like oh i already have
everything that i want so maybe just
because he's not
needy or he's not like into owning
objects or anything like that so he ca
so leland can't really get like a a fix
on him you know what i mean because
he doesn't because the thing about it is
that he kind of like
does it different for everybody like
bonnie bedelia who in this is
um you know plays polly and who is like
ed harris's girlfriend
and she has really really bad arthritis
so leland like gives her this kind of
magical amulet that like makes her
uh arthritis go away and she's like
really reluctant to give that up as you
would be so
he kind of knows like where everyone's
weak spots are
but i guess like with alan pangborn the
sheriff he since he doesn't really want
anything in particular and he's not from
there too i think they establish he's
from pitch pittsburgh right like he's
from a big city so maybe the fact that
he's not from there so he doesn't have
like these deep roots of you know hatred
with all these other people and like all
these simmering resentments that are
kind of like brought to the fore maybe
that's what it is i'm not really sure
but yeah i mean as stephen king
adaptations go this one is like a pretty
good one especially for the 1990s like i
said a lot of really really good ones
came out of the 90s like misery and
shawshank redemption and stuff like that
so it's not you know
that great compared to those but it's
still like a pretty good one it's still
like worth watching it's in the up it's
in the upper half yeah
quality yeah i mean it does
i do kind of wish they had done more
character development a little bit but
like i said i know that they didn't have
like all the time in the world um and it
does kind of like in the middle part it
gets like a little bit
repetitive i guess because it's kind of
like just the same thing it's like oh
here's this thing that you wanted and
here's this you know prank that you have
to go pull and you kind of know like
where all the wires are getting crossed
and everything like that but it's okay
and like you know and the end is like
slightly slightly cheesy but that's all
right it's it's just a very 90s
production it is yeah but but not like
bad 90s it's like okay 90s pretty good
90s yeah that's what it is and like i
said i kind of feel like this one sort
of gets forgotten about i mean which is
not
it's not surprising i guess because so
many [ __ ] do you know so many [ __ ]
adaptations of stephen king stuff has
been made that i can't even that every
now and then i'll come across one that i
didn't even know they made you know what
i'm saying like especially ones that
were based on maybe some of his novels
that aren't as well known or like his
short stories or something like every
now and then i'll come back like a
couple years back i was on netflix and i
came across
a movie
that had uh the kid that played carl and
walking dead and i think it was called
mercy but it was actually based on
stephen king's story grandma which was
from one of his old like short story
collections i was like holy [ __ ] i know
they adapted that into a movie who knew
but yeah so it's like he's written so
much stuff that it's like a lot of them
get lost in the cracks especially
because a lot of them
are you know like i said are good but
aren't really like [ __ ] amazing you
know what i mean because his stuff is
just so
i mean we talked about this when we were
talking about fire starter i guess like
his his books are so
the characterization is so rich and so
much of it like happens internally like
inside like people's thought processes
and stuff and that's really really hard
to like convey in a movie i guess yeah
so maybe that's kind of why
uh there's not that many like fantastic
ones but
uh hugo said i like all remakes of the
body snatchers also the faculty oh my
god yeah i know you know what that had
never occurred to me that that movie was
actually sort of like an invasion of the
body snatchers
a take on it but i guess it is i haven't
seen that in a long time your legs are
getting nice jenny
thanks jenny working out his legs are
turning out pretty good yeah i did a lot
i have some damn stripper shoes on there
man [ __ ]
you're gonna get laid
i'm gonna get laid yeah you're not gonna
be able to get out of this room by
yourself okay whatever yeah
yeah
no you look good though
i'm gonna get a picture you guys could
see yeah
she's going this way all right well yeah
you know certainly yeah i have like kind
of i
have a cold you know what i mean yeah uh
slash fred said i love watching tv
adaptations of movies the tv adaptation
of child's play too has some added
scenes like when one of the staff
members the good guy is driving he calls
his wife yeah that's that's the thing
it's like sometimes i guess
when they show a movie like not
theatrically a lot of times when they
show it on tv
if it if the runtime is like awkward a
lot of times they'll add in more scenes
like they'll make it longer so that it
like takes up a bigger chunk of time so
sometimes like the [ __ ] you saw in the
theater that's like not even
what they because i think they do that
with a lot of stephen king stuff to you
slasher friend said uh amanda plummer
had guest start on the first season of
tales from the crypt called lover come
hack to me oh i remember that one
i remember that one she played the wife
of a guy who marries her only for her
money yeah that was that was actually
one of the better uh episodes
i really need to rewatch the tales from
the crypt series because i've never
really really liking that
um
the chick in this film with the elvis
glasses
is the kid uh brian rusk's mother that
and watches her character from the book
which is cool because she's obsessed
with elvis oh okay yeah i see what
you're saying
uh bonnie bedelia is macaulay culkin's
aunt in real life
holy [ __ ] i didn't know that okay well
there you go
the explosion at the end was uh one hell
of a good stunt next to the gas station
explosion and christine yeah that is one
thing like the end of this with the um
the shop blowing up
i mean that looks really good it doesn't
even look like
i don't know i mean it looks like they
really blow up a building i'm assuming
they did it didn't look like miniatures
it didn't look like and it looked like
the actors were fairly fairly close to
it maybe it was optical illusion but
yeah that did look really yeah that one
house they blew that [ __ ] up they blew
that [ __ ] i saw a [ __ ]
bottom of the superstructure and the
whole [ __ ]
floor curl up and then go back down all
the wood breaking apart that was a real
house yeah they used a low explosive to
do it tnt probably well that's kind of a
high probably black powder
because uh
if you use a high explosive would have
shattered all that wood a low explosive
would just kind of heave it that's why
it was coming up there all on one piece
and just kind of flexing
but it looked cool on camera it did yeah
and i have to say i really liked um
jt walsh in this we were talking about
uh we were talking about people chewing
the scenery and how like yesterday when
we were talking about the priest and uh
in uh raw head rex and how but and jt
walsh kind of i don't want to say like
choose the scenery but he just like goes
way the [ __ ] out there with it and it's
really really fun like he just goes
completely evil at the end he's the one
i love the scenes of him
his his needful thing was this toy that
was like a it was actually pretty cool
actually it was like a little racetrack
like with horses on it he was like a
gambling addict or whatever and all you
had to do was like touch the horses and
like say the name of whatever the race
was that day and you could run the race
and it would tell you like which horses
would win so it was like supernatural
and so like some of the [ __ ] like and he
was like so he was like super mean to
his wife too he kept calling her like a
[ __ ] like all this other kind of [ __ ]
she was just kind of like she was kind
of like oh well okay then and it was
that was just like funny but yeah he was
like a funny character and like ed
harris was [ __ ] great in this i loved
like ed harris's line like when
jt walsh and like the other cop were
like arguing in the hallway or something
and he's just like that he he's like i
moved to this town like because i
thought all the worst i have to do is
like get cats out of trees so he's like
but no it's everyone is insane
everywhere that was just like so [ __ ]
funny i'm gonna have to have to reverse
my my opinion of that being black powder
there was no
no um smoke
so they must have used uh info or diesel
fuel to blow that building up
because i remember fire but no smoke
afterwards but it was weird how you
could see it in slow motion that house
[ __ ] flex them like that it looked
good on camera
yeah yeah danny rowling says the poke
stop pulling everything out of down
she's pulling it all the way
books out and then she starts licking
her she's like um no i didn't do that
that's what i do
trying to play it off huh danny rowling
says the buildings they blew up in this
film are no longer there so they must
have actually blown up i'm not actually
where did they shoot this i'm not asked
because i'm like
no
i got notes from like wikipedia but i
don't think it says like where they shot
it from either that or i deleted it
she's gonna pull every book out of the
damn book that's okay i'll put him back
where are you wow look she's so busy
trying to help you're helping huh she's
helping
help him with the show you're so funny
yeah uh danny rowling jt
walsh's performance deserved an award
for this film in my opinion some people
say it was over the top acting but i
don't think so yeah i don't think it was
over the top i mean maybe it was but it
was still like kind of fun you could
tell he was having a good time and like
max von sydow you could tell he was
absolutely having a good time like
playing the devil you know what i mean
but i mean he's my favorite thing about
it but this has such a great cast
that
it's kind of hard not to like like i
said it's not you know one of the best
stephen king adaptations but it's still
pretty [ __ ] good
uh dj maniac said never saw the movie
but i read the book did they actually
get kiefer sutherland back as ace
merrell for the film adaptation yeah we
were just talking about that earlier no
i wish they would have done that um i
don't know if they did that in the
longer tv version like if they actually
had that character
show up again because that would have
been pretty cool if they'd done that but
in the theatrical version now they don't
even mention
really in the in the movie version
i think like max von sydow he doesn't
really have like uh an assistant as such
although he does get like jt walsh's
character buster keaton that's
yeah his last name is keaton somebody
calls him buster who makes it bad but um
he gets him to do [ __ ] for him but they
don't bring up ace and i actually didn't
even remember because it had been so
long since i read the book that ace
merrell was a character in the book that
was like a crossover from the body but
yeah he's not in the theatrical version
but i don't know about the longer one
ghostface said uh this was back when tv
started when stunts were good even even
tv shows had good studs basically we
said like yeah they cared back then they
didn't have cg
and you had stuntmen that were i guess
in the in the guild
you had to keep them working
so you know it was just like even in tv
shows you saw real cars being wrecked
and
dudes [ __ ] rolling down hills over
and over again getting all [ __ ] up
but it was good man live
live stuff or not live but it in in
camera stunts
dudes getting hurt and [ __ ] it's just
better i mean well i mean and back then
before they had cgi it's like they'd
probably it probably didn't even occur
to him to them that there would be like
another way to do it someday it was just
like the way you did it and white
lightning [ __ ] burt reynolds [ __ ]
caught air in a car holding onto the
side of the truck remember
that's right yeah yeah and when it hit
the ground boom he came rolling off the
side and then ran right up to the camera
said that was burt reynolds hanging on
the side of that [ __ ] truck that was
like a horrifying stunt it was cool oh
my god you know so don't you ever
ever
let anybody say that [ __ ] burt
reynolds was not an action hero
i don't think anybody he was one of the
original stars one of the originals
man of the south
southern maine southern man camp guy
says
i think king king meant for the book to
be a semi-comedy or a funny read i
definitely get that like i said i
haven't read the book in a long time the
movie does come across as a little bit
like a black comedy now i have seen some
reviewers say that they thought that it
was mean-spirited
but i don't know if i agree with that
necessarily i could have done without
the dog getting skinned but they didn't
show it well they showed the aftermath
yeah they didn't show they didn't show
like it was just obviously a rubber dog
yeah i was just kind of like they do
kind of put man we've seen like so many
movies with [ __ ] yeah with [ __ ] uh
animal cruelty in it lately
you know what i mean it's kind of like
bothering me but yeah but i i don't know
it's just kind of
it doesn't seem mean-spirited to me but
it def it definitely does seem like a
black comedy and i can't remember if
that's the tone that stephen king had
going in the book it wouldn't surprise
me because he does have like a really
twisted sense of humor which i think
comes across in like a lot of his novels
but you know if so if you come at this
like thinking it's going to be like kind
of morbidly funny then i think it's a
lot better
um
i think what else did i have to talk
about
i'm kind of getting like
lightheaded but like my well because i
was supposed to i recorded a video today
and i we were going to record a video
but i was like oh i think my voice is
[ __ ] up so
i don't really want to strain it you
sound real
well i don't really want to strain it
because i have like other recording and
stuff that i have to do tomorrow so i
kind of want to rest it a little bit
um yeah danny rowling said wilma's
husband was clearly scared of his wife
and became an alcoholic because of it
she was scary i mean you know what i
mean she was always like going around
like [ __ ] screeching at everybody and
all that other kind of crap and telling
amanda plumber she's going to kill her
dog and all this other kind of crappy
that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up
but yeah so
i guess we'll uh cut it short i gotta
clean all these books up that
pokey pulled out and like i said i gotta
rest my voice so it doesn't get too
[ __ ] up so i can do some more
recording and live streaming tomorrow
so thanks everybody for dropping by i
think tomorrow we're gonna be talking
about
sam raimi's drag me to hell because uh i
just we just watched that the other
night so we'll probably talk about that
tomorrow
and so thanks everybody for coming to
see us today and we'll see you guys
again tomorrow evening bye